okay across a dissociative boundary why
don't you explain
how dissociative identity disorder gives
rise to some of how you view the world
um i i can sort of immediately give an
example from research there was research
done
i think at harvard um several years ago
they studied patients with the
dissociative identity disorder which are
people who seem to have multiple
alter personalities with different
memories different uh
proclivities different tastes different
ways of being
but they are in fact just dissociated
aspects of a single mind that person's
mind
now research has shown that when these
people dream
different alter personalities can
experience the same dream from different
perspectives
and they can even see their other alters
as
other avatars within the same dream i
would say that this is a great
metaphor for what might be happening
right now because the biggest argument
against this idea that mind is
fundamental
is that i can't read your thoughts and
presumably you can't read mine
so if mind is fundamental how come it
seems to be so neatly bound by
matter if matter is derivative and mind
fundamental
well i would suggest that what's
happening there is entirely analogous to
what's happening in the mind of a
patient with dissociative identity
disorder
when mental processes become
inferentially
separate from each other when they can't
evoke one another when memories become
separate
personality traits become separate we
call it dissociation and that
dissociation is bound by a so-called
dissociative boundary
we have plenty of empirical evidence for
that in psychiatry
and we have proof that this is a real
phenomenon since the beginning of
neuroimaging 20 years ago
people with did have particular
identifiable recognizable patterns of
brain activity
that differ from those that do not have
the id
people with the id can even be literally
blind by dissociation
if an outer who is blind is in control
of the body
mental activity or brain activity in the
visual cortex
has been shown to disappear and that's
not something you can fake
when you're looking around with your
eyes open and there is no activity
in your in your visual cortex and while
when another alter comes
and takes control over the body that
meant act or that brain activity returns
and is measurable again
and when you say alter you mean one of
those one of those personalities
traditionally it's called multiple
personality disorder or split
personality disorder you're just
referring to one of those
correct the way that i understand this
is that there's mind at large and then
it fractionates itself into smaller
consciousnesses that each have their own
proclivities and access to memories that
others don't much like multiple
personality disorder or dissociative
identity disorder
okay now what i'm wondering is would
this analogy still work if we didn't
refer to that person who has did
as one person so for example in your
home right now
there's you there's your cat maybe
there's some other people
and when you enter and leave i wouldn't
say that that's bernardo's split
personalities i would say he has a home
and these are different people coming in
and out so
part of the analogy you make is when we
consider
that person with multiple split multiple
personality disorder as a single
individual
split but what if we don't think of them
as a single individual anymore
we think of them as actually housing
different personalities so then
can you still make that analogy that
it's all one mind at large
look the experience of separation
definitely exists i'm having it right
now i can't read your thoughts i can't
know what's happening in the galaxy of
andromeda
and i can't influence the thoughts of
the presidents of the world's nations if
i could the world would be
looking very different right now so it
exists
as an experience in the same way that
the different altars of a person with
the id
experience the same dream from a
different perspective
so the experience of separation
exists it would be silly to deny that
because it's a basic datum of existence
what i would say is that fundamentally
there is no separation
that experience of separation is a form
of illusion
uh fundamentally it's all happening in
one
natural mind a mind that spans
uh across the universe like uh the
theoretical quantum fields in quantum
theory
um the same boundlessness is implied uh
there
um but you see if we have a
theory of reality that does justice
to reason and evidence i think that
theory
would unavoidably point to this mental
oneness at the most fundamental layer of
reality
it wouldn't invalidate our ordinary
experience because
they exist as such they exist as
experiences
but they could inform our judgment they
could inform
even our ethical systems in a much
healthier way than what's going on right
now because if you know
at least from thinking and evidence from
reason and evidence
that most likely we are all alters of
one mind
i think we would look at our perceived
enemies differently we would look at
underprivileged people in the world
differently we would
regard animal life differently
and i think that would be a good step
forward